nous avons perdu des amis les parents
des proches des collègues pour moi à la
destruction du café de lavaur ans le 25
mars 2002 c'était aussi douze années de
ma vie qui partent ans mais il y en ait
que gagner le propriétaire du café
musique café à lac mégantic a vraiment
de ces hasards absolument incroyable
journée aujourd'hui où on veut rebâtir
parler d'avenir
il y en ait gagné le député de québec
était la ministre fédérale également au
même moment
presque au même moment presque à la même
minute comparution de ces trois employés
de la mma donc à lac-mégantic
accusations criminelles négligence
criminelle vous proposons un petit
reportage émilie dubreuil qui s'est
rendu aujourd'hui à lac mégantic
la structure est toute neuve l'animent
une musique c'est rendre hommage à ceux
qui ont perdu la vie dans un musique à
fait disparu au coeur de cette tragédie
si on s'appuie sur qu'est ce qui s'est
passé et puis qu'on considère sombre et
je crois que ça fonctionne reproche pas
que des gens alors qu'ils sont partis le
message on nous offrait aujourd'hui
c'est sorte c'est continuer mais musique
porte ton rêve après que ton cas voit le
large et ma mélodie est là elle t'invite
à la vie au centre de l'édifice une
poutre mémoire où les habitants
lac-mégantic honte écrit des messages
on peut aussi y lire l'espoir c'est une
renaissance
2 mai de recommencer parce que la vie
continue
c'est bon c'est beaucoup de courage pour
les gens d'ici à la sortie du palais de
justice se compare à ses trois accusés
dans cette affaire on était loin de la
vindicte populaire
justement on a besoin de penser à demain
je réalise que le vendée u banques et
aux personnes qui ont hué tout le monde
non compris puis je pense qu'on ait
beaucoup avoir compris que c'est parce
qu'ils sont responsables qui sont
annoncés pour mir
on est encore dans le processus de
démolition
on marche mon est parmi nous des fêtes
temps d'un ici milite dubreuil l'aqmi on
poursuit la discussion avec daniel
poulin et les résidents et propriétaires
le journal local la balle journal
émerger monsieur poulet bonsoir à vous
merci d'être avec nous bonsoir monsieur
roy mais je voulais essayer de nous
faire comprendre on est loin quand même
aujourd'hui l'atmosphère aujourd'hui
c'est quand même je disais strazer assez
particulier musique a fait la vie
continue et de l'autre côté comparution
aujourd'hui au palais de justice chez
vous traite une atmosphère assez lourde
quand même lourd
je ne dirais pas faire était lourd au
niveau des trois employés de mma le
sentiment est assez mélangé chez nous
oui ces gens là ont été participants une
chaîne d'événements qui amenait des as
absolument épouvantable mais ce qu'ils
en sont réellement responsable je pense
que le respect que les gens opposés
vis-à-vis des trois personnes accusées
aujourd'hui démontre bien que pour les
gens de lac-mégantic
si monsieur broeckaert avait été ici
aujourd'hui vous auriez entendu crier
chaud jusqu'à montréal
alors quand on passe un monsieur holding
qui était le conducteur du train qui
était couché dans un motel dans une
chambre juste devant la station de
pompiers quand les pompiers sont sortis
il est allé les aider alors prenez les
gens de lac-mégantic on dit mais
pourquoi est-ce qu'on tombe ce bonhomme
là mais je dirais que monsieur la
fontaine faut bien commencer quelque
part
au niveau des musiques à fait c'est là
vraiment que les sentiments sont très
mélangées ici c'est que la musique a
fait c'était une superbe bonne nouvelle
il ya deux semaines on a une très bonne
nouvelle la réouverture de la
médiathèque
on a de belles nouvelles aujourd'hui la
musique a fait c'est un endroit de
rencontre pour les familles pour les
gens qui travaillent c'était une icône
ici à lac mégantic et finalement il y en
ait gagné avec finalement faut dire les
pressions de la population a décidé de
monter un projet d'un million six et
voilà l'endroit d'où mois de septembre
on va revoir renaître la musique a fait
est en fait semaine c'est la berge
glacée qui va rouvrir également
alors après univers monsieur roy que je
pense que nous pouvons qualifier de très
long et très difficile à lac mégantic
ben là coup sur coup on a trois belles
nouvelles et ça c'est positif
et puis ça et de la morale monsieur
poulet je veux revenir 1 terminant
justement sur ces accusations
criminelles
vous dites c'est pas dans le fond le
personnage que les gens auraient aimé
voir traîner au palais de justice
c'est le grand propriétaire des mets moi
et non pas les employés n'ont pas bu
sera digne du maître il abril ce qui
serait vraiment une bonne chose avec ce
procès c'est que ce procès devienne un
certain moment donné le procès des
entreprises comme un mmo qui sont des
entreprises qu'on se qualifie de nos
côtes
autrement dit des gens pour qui le
profit passe en premier avant tout alors
si un certain moment donné ce procès
peut nous donner la chance d'exprimer
vos doléances et ces compagnies là qui
ont aucun respect pour la personne
humaine
peut-être que le gouvernement vont
écouter et va décider un certain moment
de dire ben là on va resserrer les
règles et on va les faire respecter
alors c'est ce qu'on souhaite et ce
serait probablement la plus belle chose
qui puisse nous arriver
daniel poulin je vous salue de montréal
donc on a tous eu repenser
collectivement à vous aujourd'hui donc à
ce drame alors merci de nous avons parlé
à la prochaine merci beaucoup au revoir
si vous étiez avec nous un peu plus tôt
dans l'émission j'ai commencé à vous
présenter le reportage denis martin
chabot sur la réaction très vive du
syndicat des métallos du québec qui
dénonce les trois arrestations
aujourd'hui on fait un monsieur roy vous
allez l'entendre parle d'eux
cirque il lui aussi montre du doigt and
back end le grand patron de mma
reportage
denis martin moi c'est insultant c'est
dégueulasse airs et au delà des bruits
travailleurs le syndicat des métallos
est furieux de l'arrestation de tomb
raider at on besoin d'en venir là de
rentrer chez lui de le menotter de le
coucher à terre de sortir de l'emmener
sa place publique devant la population
de négatif aujourd'hui cette
intervention aurait été rendue
nécessaire parce que notamment tom
reading possédait des armes à feu
l'avocat de ton bras ding réfute ses
explications il avait des rêves le dd
des armes à la maison il y a deux ou
trois mois c'était une circonstance bien
spéciale
on a enlevé les hommes et aucun problème
le 6 juillet 2013
thomas ording était chef de trait il
était seul car la mm avait obtenu une
dérogation de transports canada pour
faire circuler ses convois avec un seul
membre d'équipage
au lieu de deux mais contrairement un
pilote d'avion ou un capitaine de bateau
il n'est pas seul maître à bord après
dieu le chef de train se rapporte aux
contrôleurs de la circulation
ferroviaire qui lui aussi se rapporte un
chef contrôleurs ou à d'autres instances
plus haute selon l'organisation de la
compet lorsqu'il a immobilisé son convoi
à nantes le soir de la catastrophe comme
erding était en contact avec robert
l'abri également accusé alors
contrôleurs de la circulation
ferroviaire genre de m aussi accusé
était directeur de l'exploitation le
cadre au dessus de l'abbaye
après le fut la locomotive robert labrie
a délégué un contremaître de la voie
ferrée qui n'avait pas les
qualifications requises pour immobiliser
un train pour s'assurer que tout était
en ordre
les syndicats dénoncent la culture
d'entreprise de la mma ils sont
propriétaires d'alors et bocar est aussi
transports canada
cousquer l'américain qui a toutes les
permissions du fédéral de faire ce
qu'ils font aujourd'hui un fonds des
dates et mises en ligne par des employés
de chemin de fer aux états unis et les
métallos du québec vont aussi contribuer
à la défense des accusés
ici denis martin chabot radio canada
montréal essayons d'y voir plus clair
dans ce dossier d accusation criminelle
avec nous jennifer couëlle de vous êtes
professeur à la faculté de droit de
verser d'ottawa bonsoir madame coin deux
premières questions que les gens se
posent donc comment expliquer que les
accusations sont portées sur trois
employés de la compagnie et non pas sur
ce grand patron qu'on a vu donc un bon
soir monsieur juan soit effectivement il
ya une part de moi qui n'est pas
surprise que les accusations tombent en
quelque sorte le plus bas possible
il n'y a pas nécessairement une raison
claire pour expliquer pourquoi on a
choisi ses trois employés là à part la
raison qu'ils sont les plus faciles à
cibler et dans une circonstance comme à
lac-mégantic on commence toujours à
l'endroit où est survenu l'événement et
on sort de là on rayonne pouvoir qui
sont les responsables
ce qui est vraiment lamentable c'est
qu'on a arrêté en quelque sorte notre
analyse
une fois qu'on y est arrivé à hauteur de
train et certains qui étaient au dessus
de lui
au lieu de s'interroger sur les
circonstances qui était peut-être
antérieure aux événements direct de lac
mégantic et qui pourrait justement faire
intervenir des comportements d'autres
personnes dont monsieur brocarde mais je
dois dire que les procureurs pour pas
leur reprocher nécessairement d'avoir
agi ainsi fonctionne à l'intérieur d'un
régime juridique qui mal outillés pour
répondre à ce genre de situation parce
que juste
les procureurs devront prouver en cours
cette notion de négligence criminelle
expliquez-nous qu'est ce que ça veut
dire concrètement qu'est ce qu'on doit
prouver
contrairement à son nom la négligence
criminelle
en fait c'est quelque chose de beaucoup
plus grave que la simple négligence
qu'on pourrait comprendre des noms dans
son sens de droit civil
en fait la négligence criminelle est
fondé sur l'insouciance et même une
insouciance grave une insouciance
téméraires ou déréglé nous dit le code
criminel à l'égard de la vie ou la
sécurité d'autres personnes et donc le
fardeau est considérable la négligence
criminelle c'est une infraction
difficile à prouver dans les meilleurs
de circonstance et moi je m'interroge
sur la force de la preuve que détient la
couronne pour pour justement démontré
une négligence criminelle de l'appareil
ont trois individus est ce que je
comprends bien madame quoi être qu'il
faut prouver que par exemple
tomtom harding le conducteur du train
j'ai dû mettre richard l'abri on était
tellement négligent que celle de
l'insouciance qu'ils auraient dû savoir
que faisant ce qu'ils faisaient
ça c'est un danger énorme qui vous à
courir à une population
c'était c'est exactement ça s'est il
faut bien sûr c'est des inférences parce
que personne va avouer généralement qui
se sait qu'on se comporter de cette
manière là mais effectivement il faut
démontrer que la conduite est telle que
la personne était conscient du risque et
elle a continué à faire comme elle l'a
fait en dépit de ce risque
alors c'est vraiment c'est pas tout à
fait de faire ça consciemment mais c'est
vraiment de d'agir alors qu'on compte
devrait être être conscient de ce risque
là et c'est pas un petit risque c'est un
risque important très bien généreux coin
de sa nous éclaire sur ces accusations
on va bien sûr en mettant de parler
beaucoup merci beaucoup d'avoir terrible
merci monsieur roy bonne soirée